then vma goes to
[Music]
anita
[Music]
is this
yes i'm gonna put it in my bed i'm gonna
sleep with it as usual i'm on a sleep
pedal
how does it feel you have achieved this
not only for yourself but for my whole
country as i told you earlier
this is the history like it's
we're making history tonight it's the
first time of my country having it being
an award like that and uh
and i i don't know the
the funk part that i did in the end of
my performance this rhythm was literally
like
considered a crime for so many years and
to be
being able to come here perform it it
was so special i'm so happy
[Music]
i know where's the moon person going do
you know exactly where at your house the
moon person's going what where's the
moon person going when you get home um
i haven't decided yet i want to put
somewhere everybody see
of course i think i'm gonna you know
what i'm what i'm gonna do in my toilet
that's the place everybody sees
because everybody goes to the toilet
right i don't know so they would be like
oh there's no way somebody will never
see them they cannot miss it we'll enjoy
your night how are you celebrating now i
don't know i said before i come and said
you know what i want to chill go to
sleep because i like chilling tonight
there's no way
i was like i don't see my dogs for so
long i want to rest those tomorrow i
have energy when i get home now
there's no way i'm resting you can rest
later mom i'm gonna get crazy tonight
y'all watch out for this one okay
[Music]